When my grandmother, Mollie Politzer, was just 32 years old, she got sick. So sick that she was in the hospital for months. So sick that the doctors thought she would die. So sick that finally, when all else seemed to fail, they called for a rabbi, and he changed her name. As my mom explains--
当我的祖母莫莉·波利策（Mollie Politzer）年仅32岁时，她病倒了。病得非常重，以至于她在医院住了好几个月。病得非常重，医生都以为她活不成了。病得非常重，直到最后，当一切治疗似乎都无效时，他们找来了一位拉比，他为她改了名字。正如我母亲所解释的那样——
The reason the rabbi said that they changed her name was so that when the Angel of Death came that he wouldn't know who she was. And he wouldn't take her.
拉比说他们改名字的原因是，当死神来的时候，他不知道她是谁。这样他就不会把她带走。
That's such a beautiful picture of what the Angel of Death is, that the Angel of Death could be so easily fooled. The Angel of Death is stupid. The Angel of Death is like the UPS man. Well, it says here the address. So I've got the name. Are you sure she's not here?
死神的这个形象真是太生动了，死神竟然能如此轻易地被愚弄。死神真是愚蠢。死神就像联邦快递的快递员。嗯，这里写着地址。所以我有名单。你确定她不在这里吗？
Well, it's sort of like if they put the wrong name tag on you in the hospital, then you get the wrong operation.
嗯，这有点像是如果他们在医院里给你的名字标签贴错了，那你就会接受错误的手术。
So my grandmother changed her name to fool the Angel of Death. And it worked. She survived, got well, changed her name back to what it was, lived to the age of 87. There's something so medieval about this story, so unlike my family, actually, my family which basically discarded the Old World the day that they got off the boat.
所以我祖母改了名字来愚弄死神。这招奏效了。她活了下来，恢复了健康，把名字改回了原来的样子，一直活到了87岁。这个故事有着非常浓厚的中世纪色彩，这其实和我家的情况很不一样，我的家人基本上在下船的那一天就抛弃了旧世界。
But I think it's easy to believe that there's something magical when you change your name. You change your name, you become a new person. You take on a different identity. You start over again, clean slate.
但我认为，当你改名时，很容易相信会有某种神奇的事情发生。你改了名字，你就成为了一个新人。你获得了不同的身份。你从头开始，一切从零开始。
In a way, it's a very American impulse. It's the New World. It's the move westward. It's divorce, and self-help, and 12-step programs, and Ellis Island all rolled into one. It's the story of Marilyn Monroe, and Andy Warhol, Muhammad Ali, and Malcolm X, and The Artist Formerly Known as Prince.
在某种程度上，这是一种非常美国式的冲动。这是新世界。这是向西迁移。这是离婚、自助、12步计划，以及埃利斯岛，所有这些都融为一体。这是玛丽莲·梦露、安迪·沃霍尔、穆罕默德·阿里、马尔科姆·X以及那位“曾被称为王子的艺术家”的故事。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, Name Changes, some done in innocence, some done to con people. Act One, The Procedure. Act Two, Baby Remember My Name, in which a 17-year-old tricks an entire resort town into believing that he is someone that he is not. Act Three, As Seen On Television, the story of a guy who got booked onto The David Letterman Show, didn't want to go, got a friend to take his name, and go in his place successfully. Act Four, Nom De Plume, how a guy named Tom became Camden Joy. And what he gained and what he lost when he did that. Stay with us.
来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目主题是“名字的变更”，有些是出于无心，有些则是为了诈骗。第一幕，流程。第二幕，“宝贝记住我的名字”，讲述了一个17岁的少年如何欺骗整个度假小镇，让他们相信他不是他自己。第三幕，电视所见，讲述了一个人被预订参加大卫·莱特曼秀，但他不想去，于是找了个朋友顶替他的名字成功参加的故事。第四幕，化名，讲述了一个叫汤姆的人如何变成了卡姆登·乔伊（Camden Joy）。以及他在这样做时得到了什么，又失去了什么。请继续收听。
Act One, The Procedure. In Los Angeles, to legally change your name, you show up at the LA Civil Courthouse at five minutes before 9:00, Thursday or Friday, and go to Room 208, Department 1A.
第一幕，流程。在洛杉矶，要合法更改你的名字，你需要在周四或周五上午9点前5分钟到达洛杉矶民事法院，前往208室，1A部门。
It works like this. You file a petition to change your name. That costs $189. You pay about $85 to publish your name change in the newspaper. If you're changing your kid's name, you need to prove that it's OK with the other parent or prove that you have searched for the other parent and you cannot find them. And you have to fill out a form, so they can check and make sure that you're not a registered sex offender.
流程是这样的。你提交一份更改名字的申请。费用是189美元。你需要支付大约85美元在报纸上刊登你的改名公告。如果你要更改孩子的名字，你需要证明另一位家长同意，或者证明你已经寻找过另一位家长但无法找到。而且你必须填写一份表格，以便他们核实并确保你不是注册的性犯罪者。
Imagine a line at the Department of Motor Vehicles. That's what this line looks like. Several teenage girls in white or black jeans, long, nylon coats, heavy makeup, and long, long crimped hair. A few couples stand, holding hands, and look to each other for assurance.
想象一下车管所排的长队。这条队伍看起来就是这样。几个穿着白色或黑色牛仔裤、长款尼龙外套、浓妆艳抹、留着长长烫发卷的少女。几对夫妇手牵手站着，看着对方寻求安慰。
We sent writer Margy Rochlin to watch the proceedings last Friday. 17 people showed up. There was a youngish, black guy with an afro, baggy, plaid pants, and a battered briefcase, changing his name from Damon Washington to [? Damone ?] [? Ide ?] [? Sativa. ?] A Vietnamese man named Sonny The Ang changed his name to Sonny Thomas Wu.
我们派了作家玛吉·罗克林（Margy Rochlin）去观察上周五的诉讼程序。来了17个人。有一个留着爆炸头、穿着宽松格子裤、提着破旧公文包的年轻黑人男子，要把他的名字从达蒙·华盛顿（Damon Washington）改为[? Damone ?] [? Ide ?] [? Sativa. ?]。一个叫桑尼·泰昂（Sonny The Ang）的越南男子把名字改成了桑尼·托马斯·吴（Sonny Thomas Wu）。
A schoolteacher named Carol Ann Anderson became Devakar Anderson. Her yoga teacher gave her the name. It means "angel princess." But more than half the people who come here are mothers who want to change their children's names. Apparently, they don't want to be reminded of the ex, who isn't around. We asked Margy Rochlin to describe the scene, what she saw when she visited.
一位名叫卡罗尔·安·安德森（Carol Ann Anderson）的学校老师变成了德瓦卡·安德森（Devakar Anderson）。她的瑜伽老师给了她这个名字。意思是“天使公主”。但来到这里的人中，超过一半是想改孩子名字的母亲。显然，她们不想被那个不在身边的前夫提醒。我们请玛吉·罗克林描述了现场，以及她去参观时所看到的情景。
Even without being told, people follow the rules of any legal proceeding. If they speak, they speak softly. For 15 minutes, I sit in this room, watching a line of people, one after the other, speak to the court clerk, a young woman who looks a lot like Kim Goldman, Ron Goldman's little sister, from the OJ Simpson trial.
即使没人告知，人们也会遵守任何法律诉讼的规则。如果他们说话，声音都很轻。我在这个房间里坐了15分钟，看着一排排的人，一个接一个地与法庭书记员交谈，那是一个看起来很像OJ·辛普森审判案中罗恩·戈德曼（Ron Goldman）的小妹妹金·戈德曼（Kim Goldman）的年轻女子。
Mostly, the court clerk asks and answers questions. She examines their papers and says things like, "Are you his mother?" The minutes tick by, and each of the people are addressed in the same kind, helpful tones. And then they walk out the door.
大多数情况下，书记员只是询问并回答问题。她检查他们的文件，说些诸如“你是他的母亲吗？”之类的话。时间一分一秒过去，每个人都用同样亲切、乐于助人的语调被对待。然后他们就走出去了。
And then at a certain point, I realize something. This is it. There's no more to this proceeding. In my mind, I'd imagined that the filing of the papers was going to be followed by some kind of swearing in process, like the kind that happens when you become an American citizen.
然后，在某个时刻，我意识到了一件事。就是这样了。这个程序没有更多的内容了。在我的脑海中，我曾想象提交文件后会伴随着某种宣誓程序，就像你成为美国公民时那样。
I pictured a group of people standing up with their right hand raised, and a judge banging the gavel and then making them repeat some official oath. Although I'm not sure what that could be. "I," new name goes here, "solemnly swear that I will answer to my new name and no other, so help me God."
我想象着一群人举起右手站着，法官敲着木槌，然后让他们重复某种官方誓言。虽然我不确定那会是什么。 “我，”新名字放在这里，“庄严宣誓，我将回应我的新名字，别无其他，上帝保佑我。”
Where the judge sits, there's only an empty chair and a nameplate that says, "Murray Gross, Commissioner." Later, I asked the clerk why the judge isn't around. And she says, "Oh, he is. He's been here all day long. He's in the back." And then she waves her hand in the direction of a room behind her.
法官坐的地方，只有一把空椅子和一个写着“默里·格罗斯（Murray Gross），专员”的名牌。后来，我问书记员为什么法官不在。她说：“哦，他在。他整天都在这里。他在后面。”然后她挥手指向她身后的一个房间。
The thing is, I look through the open door and I only see a secretary wandering around. And immediately, I think of the great and powerful Oz. "There's no Murray Gross," I think. In Los Angeles, if you want to get your name changed, you deal with this clerk. Her name is Robin. She's a temp.
问题是，我透过敞开的门看去，只看到一个秘书在走来走去。我立刻想到了伟大的奥兹国国王。我想，“根本没有默里·格罗斯。”在洛杉矶，如果你想改名，你就是和这个书记员打交道。她的名字是罗宾。她是个临时工。
About five deep into the line, there's a tall, thin, elderly woman with a fuzz of gray hair, who stands as patiently as the rest. She wears all white, a long, white sweater, white, sheer stockings, white shoes, and an ankle-length, crisply ironed, pleated, white skirt. There is something about her that immediately catches your eye. She's the only one in line wearing a crown, a beaded one, gold and blue.
在队伍里大约第五个人的位置，有一位身材高挑、瘦削的老妇人，头发灰白蓬松，像其他人一样耐心站着。她全身穿着白色，一件白色长毛衣，白色透明长筒袜，白色鞋子，还有一条脚踝长度、烫得笔挺的白色百褶裙。她身上有一种立刻吸引你目光的东西。她是队伍中唯一戴着皇冠的人，一顶镶珠的，金色和蓝色。
This is Her Holiness O'Bryant. Her name used to be Olivia, she tells me. But in 1981, God told her to change her name-- she wouldn't say why-- to "Her Holiness." And she respectfully complied. Ever since then, everyone at the retirement home, where she lives, calls her Her Holiness or nothing at all.
这是欧布莱恩圣下（Her Holiness O'Bryant）。她告诉我，她原来的名字叫奥利维亚（Olivia）。但在1981年，上帝告诉她要改名字——她不愿说原因——改为“圣下”。她恭敬地照做了。从那以后，她住的养老院里的每个人都叫她“圣下”，或者干脆不叫。
"What do they call you for short?" I ask her. And she smiles dreamily at me. That's it. No answer. Her Holiness has definitely dealt with bigger smart alecks than myself.
“他们简称为你什么？”我问她。她梦幻般地对我微笑。就是这样。没有回答。这位“圣下”肯定应付过比我更聪明的捣蛋鬼。
Somewhere, from the folds of her all-white costume, she pulls out a small, black, leather wallet. And she shows me her social security card and her driver's license. And they both say, "Her Holiness O'Bryant." Then she slides the cards back into the wallet, adjusts her crown with a tiny tap of her long, skinny fingers, and then she disappears off down the court hallway.
她从她那全白装束的褶皱里掏出一个黑色小皮夹。她给我看了她的社会保障卡和驾照。上面都写着“欧布莱恩圣下”。然后她把卡片滑回钱包里，用修长瘦削的手指轻轻调整了一下皇冠，然后她就消失在法院的走廊里了。
Watching this whole thing, it's hard to believe how simple it is to change something that has been so much a part of your life for so long, something that seems irrevocable, this thing you've had since birth. And when they walk out of the courtroom, people have an expression that I've only seen in one other place. It's the "what just happened?" expression of newlyweds after they've been married in a quickie wedding in Las Vegas.
看着这一切，很难相信改变一个伴随了你这么久、似乎不可撤销的、从出生就有的东西竟然如此简单。当他们走出法庭时，人们的表情是我只在另一个地方见到过的。那是拉斯维加斯闪婚后新婚夫妇那种“刚才发生了什么？”的表情。
So much anticipation has come before this. So much thought has been invested on the road to this moment. And it all happens so quickly, they don't know what to feel. They assume they're going to feel different, but they don't feel different, just numb.
在此之前有太多的期待。在通往这一刻的路上投入了太多的思考。而这一切发生得太快，他们不知道该有什么感觉。他们以为自己会有不同的感觉，但他们并没有，只是感到麻木。
Sometimes they actually say it out loud to Robin. They lean towards her and whisper, "Is that it?" "That's it," she says, moving on to the next applicant.
有时他们真的会大声对罗宾说出来。他们倾向她并低声问：“这就完了吗？” “这就完了，”她说，继续接待下一位申请人。
Margy Rochlin in Los Angeles. More name changes coming up.
洛杉矶的玛吉·罗克林报道。更多名字变更的故事即将到来。
Act Two, Baby Remember My Name. Well, to understand this next story, we have to return to American pop culture circa 1974. Writer Jack Hitt's gonna help us out.
第二幕，“宝贝记住我的名字”。好吧，要理解接下来的故事，我们必须回到1974年左右的美国流行文化。作家杰克·希特（Jack Hitt）将为我们提供帮助。
It's hard for people to understand nowadays what National Lampoon was in 1974, where everybody had to read it for whatever reason, especially if you were a 17-year-old guy.
现在的人很难理解1974年的《国家讽刺文摘》（National Lampoon）是什么样的地位，为什么每个人都必须读它，尤其是如果你是一个17岁的男孩的话。
For a certain group of American teenagers and college students, National Lampoon was what Saturday Night Live would be in the John Belushi, Gilda Radner years. In fact, some of the early Saturday Night Live staff came from the Lampoon. One of the Lampoon writers was a guy named Christopher Cerf. This next story is about Jack Hitt, now an adult, deciding as a teenager, to take Christopher Cerf's name in the year 1974 for himself. We invited Mr. Hitt into a studio and, to keep things fair, Mr. Cerf.
对于某一部分美国青少年和大学生来说，《国家讽刺文摘》就是约翰·贝鲁西（John Belushi）和吉尔达·拉德纳（Gilda Radner）时期的《周六夜现场》。事实上，一些早期的《周六夜现场》员工就是来自《国家讽刺文摘》。其中一位作家叫克里斯托弗·瑟夫（Christopher Cerf）。接下来的故事是关于杰克·希特，现在他已经成年，回想起他在1974年作为一个十几岁的少年决定冒用克里斯托弗·瑟夫的名字。我们邀请了希特先生来到演播室，为了公平起见，也邀请了瑟夫先生。
You picked me out of all the writers you could have picked. It's startling, especially when you don't hear about it 'til 20 years later or so.
你从所有能挑选的作家中选中了我。这太惊人了，尤其是你直到20年后左右才听说这件事。
Mr. Cerf's assignment for this studio session was to interview Jack Hitt about the incident. Up until this moment, the two had never met. Chris seemed very happy to be asked. Jack seemed very, very happy to tell his story.
瑟夫先生这次录音的任务是采访杰克·希特关于那次事件的情况。直到这一刻，两人从未见过面。克里斯似乎很高兴被邀请。杰克似乎非常、非常高兴讲述他的故事。
The whole story starts in-- it's the summer of '74. And I was 17 years old, a rising senior in high school. And my friend Jimmy had a country house in the highlands of North Carolina, this little town called-- I think it's-- Brevard.
整个故事开始于——那是74年的夏天。我当时17岁，高中的准高三学生。我的朋友吉米（Jimmy）在北卡罗来纳州的高地有一个乡村别墅，在这个叫——我想是——布雷瓦德（Brevard）的小镇。
And on the way up, we were just talking about all the people that he had gotten to know over the years up there. He knew most of the families. And they're fairly wealthy, well-to-do people. And he knew a lot of the kids and stuff, the other teenagers up there.
在去的路上，我们只是在谈论他多年来在那里认识的所有人。他认识大多数家庭。他们都是相当富有、优越的人。他认识那里的很多孩子之类的，其他的青少年。
And so somehow, between the two of us, we came up with the idea that I would just be somebody else. And we'd just have a couple of day's fun, hoodwinking everybody with pretending that I was somebody I wasn't. So we were reading a couple of different articles, and we came across one of yours.
所以不知怎的，我们两个想出了一个主意，那就是我就伪装成别人。我们会用几天时间开开心心地欺骗大家，假装我不是我。所以我们正在读几篇不同的文章，我们偶然读到了你的一篇。
All of those names, by the way-- you have to remember that your name, O'Rourke's name, Donoghue's name, all those names were, to a 17-year-old male in 1974, these were the names of gods.
顺便说一句，所有这些名字——你必须记住，在1974年，对于一个17岁的男性来说，你的名字、奥罗克（O'Rourke）的名字、多诺霍（Donoghue）的名字，所有这些名字都是神的名字。
I'm honored. I'm honored.
我很荣幸。我很荣幸。
At last, I'm here.
终于，我来了。
At last somebody thinks I'm a god. It only took 23 years.
终于有人认为我是神了。这只花了23年。
So anyway, so we decided that I would be you. We decided we weren't going to be too ham-fisted about it. We'd come into the town, we'd go out, see some of the people, and he would just introduce me as Chris Cerf. And no one would say anything.
所以无论如何，我们决定我就成为你。我们决定不做得太露骨。我们走进镇上，我们出去，见一些人，他就会把我介绍为克里斯·瑟夫。没有人会说什么。
And if it came up in conversation, slowly but surely, I began to retail this gigantic lie. And the lie was that I was a junior at Harvard. And in my spare time, I was freelancing as a writer for the National Lampoon. And of course, to say that, and to say Christopher Cerf's name at that time was-- everyone got it.
如果谈话中提到了，我就会慢慢地、肯定地开始兜售这个巨大的谎言。谎言就是我是哈佛大学的大三学生。业余时间，我还在为《国家讽刺文摘》做自由撰稿人。当然，在那个时候说出那句话，说出克里斯托弗·瑟夫的名字——每个人都懂。
Everyone that we talked to up there, the minute I'd say that, they'd go, "You're Christopher Cerf?" I'd say, "Yeah, have you seen my stuff? I write occasionally in a little magazine called the National Lampoon. Maybe you've heard of it?" That kind of thing.
我们在那里谈过的每一个人，我一说出口，他们就会说：“你是克里斯托弗·瑟夫？”我会说：“是啊，你看过我的文章吗？我偶尔会在一本叫《国家讽刺文摘》的小杂志上写文章。也许你听说过？”就是那种风格。
Anyway, it went over way too well. Within 48 hours, I was the hottest commodity on the mountain. It was fabulous. Let me just say, being you for those first three or four days was just absolutely the best for a couple reasons.
不管怎样，效果太好了。在48小时内，我就成了山上最红的人物。真是棒极了。让我说，头三四天当你的感觉绝对是最好的，原因有几个。
But mainly because I suddenly found out that being somewhat famous made people laugh at your jokes just a lot more quickly. I didn't have to do any work at all. I was used to being the guy that had to really put on a big, big show to get the smallest laugh. Now anything I said got an incredible reaction because, of course, everybody was trying to kiss up to me. Because I was Christopher Cerf.
但主要是因为我突然发现，有点名气让人笑话你的笑话快得多。我根本不需要做任何努力。我习惯于成为那个必须真的卖力表演才能得到哪怕一点点笑声的家伙。现在我说的任何话都能得到令人难以置信的反应，因为当然，每个人都在试图巴结我。因为我是克里斯托弗·瑟夫。
Yeah. But what amuses me is that you had absolutely no idea what I was like or anything.
是啊。但让我觉得好笑的是，你根本不知道我长什么样或者其他什么。
No.
不。
Just that you made me up.
只是你编造了我。
Right. And I was giving people publishing advice, too. That was the other thing. And I realize now that I've been a magazine writer for 22 years, and edited, and so forth, that advice was actually pretty right on.
没错。而且我还在给别人提供出版建议。那是另一件事。我现在意识到，作为一个杂志撰稿人已经22年了，编辑过文章等等，当时的建议其实相当准确。
Is there anybody whose career that I helped a lot that you can tell me about now that made it?
有没有什么人的职业生涯是你帮了大忙，现在能告诉我的？
I don't remember any of the names unfortunately. I do remember one time being at a party, and there were two girls vying for my affection in this really wonderfully aggressive, teenage way, where they're both trying to out-entertain each other in my eyes. And it was clear that one of these two girls wanted to be my regular date for the time that I was going to be up there. This was going to be a summertime fling. That night, one thing led to another, and I somehow fell in with the really good-looking brunette one.
不幸的是，我不记得任何名字了。我确实记得有一次在聚会上，有两个女孩以一种非常美妙、好胜的青少年方式争夺我的青睐，她们都在试图在我的眼中超越对方。很明显，这两个女孩中的一个想成为我待在那段时间里的固定约会对象。这将是一场夏日恋情。那天晚上，事情发生了变化，我不知何故和那个非常漂亮的黑发姑娘搞在了一起。
I'm amazed you picked her.
我很惊讶你选了她。
All I remember is that we did neck in the corner of the room late at night. And I felt-- that was a very strange moment. With your fame, I got to neck with this really beautiful brunette.
我只记得我们在深夜房间的角落里亲热。我感觉——那是一个非常奇怪的时刻。借着你的名气，我和这个非常漂亮的黑发姑娘亲热了。
That's what makes me so damn angry. Because that's my girl. I loved her, Jack. She's mine.
这让我该死地生气。因为那是我的女孩。我爱她，杰克。她是我的。
As I say, what amazes me about this story is that that never worked for me. I didn't say, "I'm Chris Cerf," and people didn't say, "Wow."
正如我所说，这个故事让我感到惊讶的是，那招对我从来没用过。我没有说“我是克里斯·瑟夫”，人们也没有说“哇”。
Well, the problem is you weren't hanging out with 17-year-olds.
好吧，问题是你当时没有和17岁的人混在一起。
I should have gone to North Carolina. Well, that's true. I should have gone to North Carolina. I knew it. Did anyone ask you about particular articles that you'd supposedly written? Because that might have been tricky.
我应该去北卡罗来纳州。嗯，这是真的。我应该去北卡罗来纳州。我知道。有没有人问过你所谓的你写的文章？因为那可能会很棘手。
Well, first of all, I knew the entire magazine from issue one up until whatever month it was at that time. But there was one guy who figured me out. There was one guy who was even more of a National Lampoon freak than I was or than Jimmy was. He lived out of a VW bug-- I'm not even sure what he was doing up there-- he lived out of a VW bug with all the National Lampoons stuck in the slot in the back. And he read them compulsively. He was beyond any of us in terms of his Lampoon fanaticism.
首先，我从第一期到当时出的月份，整个杂志的内容我都知道。但有一个人拆穿了我。有一个人比我或吉米更像《国家讽刺文摘》的狂热分子。他住在甲壳虫车里——我甚至不确定他在那里做什么——他住在甲壳虫车里，所有的《国家讽刺文摘》都插在后面的槽里。他强迫性地阅读它们。他在文摘迷程度方面超越了我们所有人。
But at first, he was very excited to meet me and was just going on. I signed copies of the magazine for him, the whole thing. And he would talk to me about different articles. And of course, I would always direct the conversation to articles of yours that I knew at the time. But he knew every one of your articles. And I remember this. We were on the porch of Jimmy's house, where I just kept slipping up. And I could see it.
但起初，他见到我很兴奋，一直喋喋不休。我给他签了杂志，全部弄好了。他会和我谈论不同的文章。当然，我总是把谈话引向我当时知道的你的文章。但他了解你的每一篇文章。我记得这个。我们在吉米的房子的门廊上，我一直说漏嘴。我能看出来。
You mean he would say, "Do you remember this one?"
你是说他会说，“你记得这一篇吗？”
Right. Or "How did you get the idea for this article?" And then, at one point, he pulled something like that. And of course, it wasn't an article that I had written. It was an article that Doug Kenney had written. But there was definitely a moment where you could almost see it in his eyes, where he suddenly realized that he was being had.
对。或者“你是怎么想到这篇文章的？”然后，有一次，他抛出了类似的问题。当然，那不是我写的文章。那是道格·肯尼（Doug Kenney）写的文章。但确实有那么一瞬间，你几乎可以在他的眼神中看到，他突然意识到自己被骗了。
And he suddenly said, "You're not Chris Cerf?"
他突然说：“你不是克里斯·瑟夫？”
Yeah. He goes, "I know you're not Christopher Cerf." And I just told him, "You're right. I'm a complete fraud."
是的。他说：“我知道你不是克里斯托弗·瑟夫。”我只是告诉他：“你说得对。我完全是个骗子。”
He laughed.
他笑了。
And then he loved it. As soon as he was in on the joke, then that was cool. He was totally cool once he was part of the prank, then he played along.
然后他喜欢上了。一旦他知道了这个笑话，那就酷了。一旦他成为恶作剧的一部分，他就完全酷了，然后他也配合着演。
That, actually, I've always found is the best thing that happens with a hoax anyway. Once one person gets it, you bring them in on it. And then it gets better and better.
事实上，我一直认为这是恶作剧发生的最好结果。一旦有人明白了，你就把他们拉进来。然后它会变得越来越好。
Well, having a confederate, yeah, definitely made it OK. Because then, of course, he was serving as a kind of front man too. He was going out into other parties and going, "See that guy over there? You know who that is? That's Christopher Cerf. Writes for the National Lampoon. "
好吧，有一个同谋，是的，绝对让事情变得没问题了。因为那时，当然，他也充当了某种幌子。他走到其他聚会上说：“看见那边的家伙了吗？你知道那是谁吗？那是克里斯托弗·瑟夫。为《国家讽刺文摘》写稿。”
What else did I do besides write for the Lampoon? Do you remember? I mean, in your view.
除了给文摘写稿，我还做了什么？你还记得吗？我是说，在你看来。
Well, I was a junior at Harvard. And I was majoring in English.
嗯，我是哈佛大学的大三学生。我主修英语。
That was right actually.
那其实是对的。
I remember saying things like, "I was studying with Harold Bloom," who, of course, doesn't teach at Harvard. He's Yale.
我记得我说过这样的话：“我和哈罗德·布鲁姆（Harold Bloom）一起学习，”他当然不在哈佛教书。他在耶鲁。
Ivy League, what the heck. No, he came up to tutor me at Harvard.
常春藤盟校，管他呢。不，他来哈佛给我辅导了。
Oh, yes. Right. Of course. Yeah. So where did you go to college?
哦，是的。对。当然。那你去哪里读大学？
I went to Harvard. You had it right.
我去了哈佛。你说对了。
I got that right? I just made that up. Were you on The Harvard Lampoon?
我说对了？我只是编的。你是《哈佛讽刺文摘》（The Harvard Lampoon）的吗？
Yes, I was. And a lot of us were. So that wasn't a bad guess. And Henry Beard and Doug Kenney were from The Harvard Lampoon, who really started the magazine. Jack, was there any point at which you regretted this, where you felt, "Oh my gosh, I've misled people?"
是的，我是。我们很多人都是。所以那不是个坏猜测。亨利·贝尔德（Henry Beard）和道格·肯尼来自《哈佛讽刺文摘》，他们真正创办了这本杂志。杰克，有没有什么时刻你后悔过，觉得“天哪，我误导了别人？”
There was a moment that was very Hitchcockian, where we all went off to play a round robin of tennis at the local club. And everybody on the mountain top has signed up for this. And from time to time over the loudspeaker, they would call the next pair to go play in this round robin.
有一个时刻非常希区柯克式，我们大家都去当地俱乐部打网球循环赛。山顶上的每个人都报名参加了这个比赛。不时地，他们会通过扩音器呼叫下一组去比赛。
And I remember it was a particularly strange moment when I was just wandering around this country club grounds with my tennis racket and, all of a sudden, hearing over the loudspeaker, "Christopher Cerf, Christopher Cerf, please report to court seven." And all of a sudden, I realized I was Christopher Cerf. I was more Christopher Cerf than you probably ever were.
我记得这是一个特别奇怪的时刻，我正拿着网球拍在乡村俱乐部的场地上徘徊，突然，听到扩音器里说：“克里斯托弗·瑟夫，克里斯托弗·瑟夫，请到七号场地报到。”突然，我意识到我就是克里斯托弗·瑟夫。我比你可能曾经是的样子更像克里斯托弗·瑟夫。
I think so. I was going to say, maybe I should just give it back to you.
我想是吧。我正想说，也许我应该把它还给你。
At that point, I think, people I know started calling me "Chris." That was really unnerving for a while. And it was around that time that, I have to say, I began to resent being Christopher Cerf because the psychic weight of having to carry around all this huge collection of lies and trying to remember constantly to whom I had told which set of lies, I was just exhausted really.
在那一点上，我想，我认识的人开始叫我“克里斯”。那段时间真的让人很不自在。也就是在那个时候，我不得不说，我开始讨厌成为克里斯托弗·瑟夫，因为背负着这一堆巨大的谎言，并试图不断地记住我对谁说了哪一套谎言的心理压力，我真的精疲力竭了。
I was just really tired of putting on the pretense. And I was tired of getting all these easy laughs. And I was tired of all these people hounding me for tips on how to get into Redbook and all the things that these 17-year-old girls want to publish in. I didn't have any real answers, and I felt like a complete ass by the end of it.
我真的厌倦了伪装。我厌倦了得到所有这些廉价的笑声。我厌倦了所有这些人缠着我询问如何进入《红书》（Redbook）杂志，以及这些17岁女孩想要发表的所有东西。我没有任何真正的答案，到最后我觉得自己像个十足的笨蛋。
Well, was there any friends that you made there that expected to see you after you left? Because that would've been a real problem, I would think. You would have told them, I guess.
那么，有没有你在那里结交的朋友，离开后还期望见到你？因为那会是个大问题，我想。你可能告诉过他们，我猜。
I did tell the one couple that we'd gotten to know the most, the closest. It was a married couple. And they were probably about 27 or 28, 10 years older than us at the time. And we had really gotten to be really good friends with them. We'd spent almost every day of the two weeks with them, been out camping with them, done all kinds of stuff.
我确实告诉了我们最了解的那对夫妇，最亲密的那一对。那是一对已婚夫妇。他们当时大概27或28岁，比我们大10岁。我们确实和他们成了很好的朋友。我们几乎每天都和他们在一起，和他们一起露营，做了各种各样的事。
And at the end of the two weeks, we thought we'd tell them because we thought, "They'll really, really dig this joke." They didn't. It was horrifying.
两周结束时，我们想我们应该告诉他们，因为我们想，“他们会真的、真的喜欢这个笑话。”他们没有。那太可怕了。
We were sitting in their cabin. And I told them that I was just Jack Hitt, this junior in high school in Charleston, South Carolina. And I'd never published a thing in my life. And they blew. They went berserk. They cursed us and threw us out of the house. And we never saw them again.
我们坐在他们的木屋里。我告诉他们我只是杰克·希特，南卡罗来纳州查尔斯顿的一名高三学生。我这辈子从来没发表过任何东西。他们炸了。他们疯了。他们诅咒我们，把我们赶出了房子。我们再也没见过他们。
Jack Hitt and Christopher Cerf. In 1974, when Jack Hitt was pulling this prank, Cerf was in his early 30s, living in Manhattan, going to parties where nobody ever, he says, gave him this kind of adulation. He became a writer for Sesame Street, author of the song "The Letter B," and many other well-known Sesame Street songs, and says that he was in on his share of pranks also.
杰克·希特和克里斯托弗·瑟夫。1974年，当杰克·希特在搞这个恶作剧时，瑟夫30出头，住在曼哈顿，去参加聚会，他说从来没有人给他这种奉承。他后来成为《芝麻街》的作家，歌曲《字母B》的作者，以及许多其他著名的《芝麻街》歌曲的作者，并说他也参与过自己的恶作剧。
When I first got to Sesame Street, correctly so, everybody was very worried about whether our books and records and things would look like we were commercializing the program. And we wanted to make it very clear that we weren't. And everybody was being very careful to make sure everything was educational and priced at the right point.
我刚到《芝麻街》时，理所当然地，每个人都非常担心我们的书、唱片和东西是否看起来像是在商业化这个节目。我们想非常明确地表示我们没有。每个人都非常小心，确保一切都是教育性的，并且价格合理。
And some people at Children's TV Workshop-- the producers were so fanatic about this that Joe Raposo, who was the main composer and music director, and I decided we would make the most commercial product that we could possibly imagine, as a joke, and give it to Joan Cooney, the founder of Sesame Street , for a Christmas present. Joe had a friend who was a butcher. So we made up Sesame Street Imperial Polish Kielbasas. We made 25 of them. And they had a little picture of Cookie Monster with a crown saying, "It's better than cookie" on it.
儿童电视工作室（CTW）的一些人——制作人对此太狂热了，以至于担任主要作曲和音乐总监的乔·拉波索（Joe Raposo）和我决定，我们要做一个我们能想象到的最商业化的产品，作为一个笑话，把它作为圣诞礼物送给《芝麻街》的创始人琼·库尼（Joan Cooney）。乔有个朋友是屠夫。所以我们制作了“芝麻街御用波兰基尔巴萨香肠”。我们做了25根。上面有一张饼干怪兽戴着皇冠的照片，写着“比饼干更好”。
And we obviously had too much time in those days because Big Bird and Cookie Monster, Carroll Spinney and Frank Oz, made a series of radio spots, fake ones, and we had the band on them. We spent a lot of time on this joke. And we had labels printed. And it had a little disclaimer on it, saying, "This educational sausage," et cetera, "is being made for the good of your children." And we made up about 100 of them to give out at Christmas time.
而且那时候我们显然有太多的时间，因为大鸟和饼干怪兽，卡罗尔·斯宾尼（Carroll Spinney）和弗兰克·奥兹（Frank Oz），制作了一系列广播广告，假的，我们有乐队在上面。我们在笑话上花了很多时间。我们印了标签。上面还有一个小免责声明，写着：“这种教育香肠”，等等，“是为了你们孩子的利益而制作的”。我们在圣诞节期间分发了大约100根。
And a few days before Christmas, we put them in the refrigerator in the lunchroom there. And lo and behold, that night, the janitor found them, and decided they were real, and that this was a real product, and it had been done illegally on the sly. And it was just like the hoax you were talking about. The minute that anybody found out about it, we just let them in on the joke, and they joined it.
在圣诞节前几天，我们把它们放在了那里的午餐室冰箱里。没想到，那天晚上，清洁工发现了它们，认为它们是真的，认为这是一个真实的产品，并且是偷偷非法完成的。就像你刚才说的那个恶作剧一样。一旦有人发现了，我们就让他们加入笑话，然后他们就参与进来了。
And the lawyers for CTW went crazy. They thought it was real. They ran a D&B on the Imperial Sausage Company. And we were always one--
而CTW的律师们疯了。他们以为是真的。他们对“御用香肠公司”进行了邓白氏（D&B）调查。我们总是——
What's a D&B?
什么是邓白氏？
A D&B. A Dunn and Bradstreet report. And they were looking for these guys. And we just kept staying one step ahead of them.
邓白氏。一份邓白氏信用报告。他们一直在找这些家伙。而我们只是保持领先他们一步。
We found a guy in Mill Valley who claimed to be Dominick Imperiale who had founded this company. He called Joan Cooney to thank her for the license. Then we had a radio station send in our spots, saying, "Are you sure you really want to run these?" And then Joan got a call from Links, the sausage monthly magazine, asking her for an interview. And it just went on and on.
我们在米尔谷（Mill Valley）找到了一个自称是多米尼克·因佩里亚莱（Dominick Imperiale）的家伙，他创办了这家公司。他打电话给琼·库尼感谢她的授权。然后我们让一家电台寄来了我们的广告，说：“你们真的想播这些吗？”然后琼接到了香肠月刊杂志《Links》的电话，请求采访她。事情接二连三地发生。
And finally, at the very end, we dressed the entire Sesame Street band up in lederhosen. And they came in with tubas and things and played "Merry Christmas" to her. And we gave her the sausages and fessed up. But it was a great hoax.
最后，在最后，我们给整个《芝麻街》乐队穿上了皮裤。他们带着大号之类的东西进来，给她演奏了“圣诞快乐”。我们把香肠给了她并坦白了。但这是一个伟大的恶作剧。
Coming up, a story David Letterman doesn't want you to hear, as if there's only one. That's in a minute when our program continues.
接下来，一个大卫·莱特曼不想让你听到的故事，就好像只有一个一样。一会儿节目继续时播出。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of writers and performers to tackle that theme with short stories, radio monologues, essays, the occasional radio play, whatever we can think of. Today's program, Name Change.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们的节目，当然，我们选择一个主题，邀请各种作家和表演者通过短篇小说、广播独白、散文、偶尔的广播剧，任何我们能想到的东西来应对这个主题。今天的节目，名字变更。
And when the radio staff and I started to assemble stories for today's show, all the stories seemed to divide off into two basic types, the stories about people who changed their name seeking a new life, a new beginning, and the stories about people changing their name hoping to perpetrate a con, a swindle. This next story falls into the second category, though it's a very small con, a very innocent con. Nobody gets hurt. No property is damaged. Nobody's feelings are wounded. It is about as innocent a swindle as they come.
当广播团队和我开始为今天的节目组装故事时，所有的故事似乎分成了两种基本类型，关于那些为了寻求新生活、新开始而改名的人的故事，以及关于那些为了进行诈骗、骗局而改名的人的故事。接下来的故事属于第二类，尽管这是一个非常小的骗局，一个非常无辜的骗局。没有人受伤。没有财产损坏。没有人的感情受到伤害。这是最无辜的骗局。
What these guys do, essentially, is appear on The David Letterman Show under a false name and identity. We've arrived at Act Three of our program, As Seen On Television.
本质上，这些家伙所做的就是以虚假的名字和身份出现在大卫·莱特曼的节目中。我们已经到了节目的第三幕，电视所见。
When I was first told to expect an invitation to appear on David Letterman's show, my only response was, "Thanks, but no thanks."
当我第一次被告知要期待大卫·莱特曼节目的邀请时，我的唯一回应是，“谢谢，但不用了。”
This is Dishwasher Pete, author of a zine called Dishwasher. I just realized, do I have to explain what a zine is? OK, for those of you who have not seen what zines are, zines are these little self-published, often xeroxed magazines. This particular one recounts the real-life adventures of Dishwasher Pete on his ongoing quest to wash dishes in every state in the Union. It's a combination diary and philosophical inquiry into the nature of dishwashing, what it means to wash dishes for a living. And it's so well written, and funny, and evocative that it has gotten some attention from the mainstream media.
这是洗碗工皮特（Dishwasher Pete），一本名为《洗碗工》的杂志的作者。我刚意识到，我必须解释什么是“zine”吗？好吧，对于那些还没看过什么是zine的人，zine是这些小的自费出版、通常是复印的杂志。这本特别的杂志讲述了洗碗工皮特在所有联邦州洗碗的持续追求中的真实生活冒险。这是日记和关于洗碗本质的哲学探究的结合，关于以洗碗为生意味着什么。而且它写得太好、太有趣、太生动了，以至于得到了主流媒体的一些关注。
Back when reporters from newspapers and magazines first started contacting me, I did a couple of interviews. One resulting article was so hokey, "Hey, look at this wacky guy," that, naturally, it made its way into newspapers around the country. Before long, I began to get exasperated with media folks. Then came the final straw.
早在报纸和杂志的记者第一次开始联系我时，我做了几次采访。其中一篇文章非常老套，“嘿，看看这个古怪的家伙”，自然而然地，它出现在全国各地的报纸上。没过多久，我就开始对媒体人员感到恼火。然后压死骆驼的最后一根稻草来了。
A producer from CNN somehow tracked down my parents' phone number and called them three times a week for nearly a month, urging my folks to have me call him. I made the call, but I happened to mention my apprehension towards the media. He took it personally and became defensive. He explained that he was "down with the cause," his very words, and didn't always work for "the man," but was forced to because he had a mortgage to pay, a family to feed, and, get this, had to put shoes on his children's feet.
CNN的一位制片人不知怎么追踪到了我父母的电话号码，并在近一个月内每周给他们打电话三次，敦促我父母让我给他回电话。我打了那个电话，但我顺便提到了我对媒体的担忧。他个人受到了冒犯，变得防御性起来。他解释说他“赞同这项事业”，这是他的原话，并不总是为“当权派”工作，而是被迫这样做，因为他有抵押贷款要付，有一家子要养，而且，听着，他得给他的孩子们买鞋穿。
I couldn't make this up if I tried. He was actually implying that if I didn't do the interview with him, then his two daughters were going to go barefoot. I had enough.
如果我想编造，我编不出来。他实际上是在暗示如果我不接受他的采访，那么他的两个女儿就会光着脚。我受够了。
From that point on, whenever a letter arrived in the stationary of some big media outlet from Los Angeles or New York, it went straight into the garbage can, unopened. But at some point, a friend of Pete's, Jess Hilliard, said that he would love to be in Pete's shoes. He'd love to be on TV. Pete figured, why deprive him of his dream? He promised that if another offer came in, he would call Jess, and Jess could go as his stand-in.
从那时起，每当一封印有洛杉矶或纽约大媒体机构信头的信件到达时，它就会直接被扔进垃圾桶，没拆封。但在某个时候，皮特的朋友杰斯·希利亚德（Jess Hilliard）说他很乐意穿上皮特的鞋子。他很想上电视。皮特心想，为什么要剥夺他的梦想呢？他承诺如果还有邀请，他会给杰斯打电话，杰斯可以作为他的替身去。
Soon a letter arrived from The Letterman Show. Like a prop in some sort of old, 1960s, Barbra Streisand, Ryan O'Neal movie-- soon a letter arrives in the mail from The Letterman Show. Pete kept to his promise. Having Jess impersonate him on national television, as far as he was concerned, had two big appealing things to it. Number one, Jess could get a free trip to New York, where Pete was living at the time, and the two of them could hang out. And number two, free food. There'd be free food, an unimaginable quantity of it, backstage at The Letterman Show. Pete would just tag along on the taping.
不久，一封来自《莱特曼秀》的信寄到了。就像60年代芭芭拉·史翠珊（Barbra Streisand）、瑞安·奥尼尔（Ryan O'Neal）电影里的道具一样——不久信箱里就收到了一封来自《莱特曼秀》的信。皮特信守了承诺。在他看来，让杰斯在全国电视上冒充他有两件非常吸引人的事。第一，杰斯可以得到一次去纽约的免费旅行，皮特当时住在那里，他们俩可以一起玩。第二，免费食物。在《莱特曼秀》的后台会有免费食物，难以想象的数量。皮特只是跟着去录制。
Because if there was going to be free food, then I was going to be right there beside him.
因为如果有免费食物，那我就要紧挨着他。
And here, our saga begins. The Letterman Show was so excited to book Dishwasher Pete-- they had heard, after all, that he was impossible to get on TV-- that they talked to Jess, thinking that he's Pete, every day for a week.
这里，我们的传奇开始了。莱特曼节目对预约洗碗工皮特感到非常兴奋——毕竟，他们听说他很难在电视上请到——以至于他们每天都和杰斯谈话，以为他是皮特，持续了一周。
And when a guest cancels out at the last minute for the TV show, they fly Jess to New York that very day. He arrives. They tell him, "No, no, no, we don't need you." Put him up for a night in a hotel, send him back home. 10 days later, fly him to New York again.
当电视节目的一位嘉宾在最后一分钟取消时，他们当天就把杰斯飞到了纽约。他到了。他们告诉他，“不，不，不，我们不需要你了。”让他住了一晚酒店，送他回家。10天后，再次把他飞到纽约。
I met him at the airport, and we rode into the city in a stretch limousine. At the hotel, Jess was greeted grimly by the staff at the desk. They remembered him from the week before when they had difficulties trying to squeeze a room deposit out of him.
我在机场接他，我们坐着一辆加长豪华轿车进了城。在酒店，杰斯受到了前台工作人员阴沉的迎接。他们还记得他上一周的情况，当时他们试图从他那里挤出房间押金时遇到了困难。
They wanted a credit card. He didn't have one. They wanted $150 cash. Jess didn't have it. With both parties frustrated, they had agreed on a $20 cash deposit.
他们想要一张信用卡。他没有。他们想要150美元现金。杰斯没有。双方都感到沮丧，他们最终商定了一笔20美元的现金押金。
But this time, Jess was determined to not even give up that much. "Oh yeah, I remember you," the desk clerk grumbled. Jess told them that if they wanted a deposit, they'd have to get it from The Letterman Show. When they called the show, whoever was on the other end, while saying that they would cover the deposit, apparently explained that Jess was a dishwasher. The clerk snorted, "Oh, is that what he does?" I emptied the candy dish into my pocket, and we went upstairs to our suite.
但这一次，杰斯决心连那么多也不给。“哦，对了，我记得你，”前台职员嘟囔着。杰斯告诉他们，如果他们想要押金，他们得从莱特曼节目那边要。当他们给节目组打电话时，电话那边的人，虽然说他们会承担押金，但显然解释了杰斯是个洗碗工。职员哼了一声，“哦，这就是他做的？”我把糖果盘清空进我的口袋，我们上了套房。
We spent the rest of the night goofing around in the hotel's gym and roaming about in our complimentary, pillowy, white robes, raiding food service trays left in the hallways. I slept for only a couple of hours before getting up around 6:00 AM. Jess was still awake, writing letters. Later in the morning, I went downtown to pick up my disguise, a suit. I slowly made my way back up to Midtown.
我们剩下的时间都在酒店健身房里胡闹，穿着赠送的、枕头般的白色长袍到处逛，洗劫走廊里留下的餐饮托盘。我只睡了几个小时，大约早上6点就起床了。杰斯还没睡，正在写信。当天晚些时候，我下城去取我的伪装，一套西装。我慢慢地往中城走。
When I reached the hotel room, Jess looked a bit worried, having just completed a series of phone calls with Letterman's staff. In the weeks prior, they had been asking Jess to send them more issues of Dishwasher. And while Jess kept telling them he would, he never did. The more issues they had meant the more material Jess would be responsible for knowing as his own.
当我到达酒店房间时，杰斯看起来有点担心，因为他刚和莱特曼的员工打完一系列电话。在之前几周，他们一直要求杰斯给他们寄更多期的《洗碗工》。而当杰斯一直告诉他们他会寄时，他从来没寄过。他们拥有的期数越多，杰斯就得负责了解更多的内容作为他自己的材料。
But now, Jess had just learned, during the previous days, they had a researcher working to track down any information by or about me. So he had no idea what they had come up with, what Jess would have to answer to. And worst of all, we didn't know if they had found a photo of me.
但现在，杰斯刚了解到，在过去几天里，他们有一个研究员在努力追踪关于我或关于我的任何信息。所以他不知道他们发现了什么，杰斯将不得不回答什么。最糟糕的是，我们不知道他们是否找到了一张我的照片。
Before the phone could ring again, we took a few beers and snuck up onto the roof of the 55-story hotel. We sat up there devising alibis to explain why Jess was Pete even if a photo might identify me as Pete. Satisfied with our arsenal of defenses and hungry from fasting all day in preparation for the free eats, it was time to go.
在电话再次响起之前，我们拿了几罐啤酒，溜到了55层酒店的屋顶上。我们坐在那里编造不在场证明，以解释为什么杰斯是皮特，即使照片可能会把我认作是皮特。对我们的防御手段感到满意，并且为了准备免费大餐而禁食了一整天感到饥饿，是时候出发了。
We went downstairs to the awaiting limo with its thick-necked driver and thicker-necked bodyguard. The studio is right around the corner from the hotel. The distance can be covered on foot in two or three minutes. And even I, with my slow pace and my need to check the pay phones for quarters, could have made the trek in five minutes. But with Midtown Manhattan's traffic locked in rush-hour gridlock and all the one-way streets working against us, it took a full half hour to make the trip in the limousine.
我们下楼到了等待的豪华轿车，带着厚脖子的司机和更厚脖子的保镖。摄影棚就在酒店拐角处。步行两三分钟就能到。即使是我，以我的慢节奏和需要检查公用电话是否有硬币的需求，也能在五分钟内走完。但由于曼哈顿中城的交通陷入了交通拥堵，所有的单行道都与我们作对，坐豪华轿车花了整整半小时。
Outside the studio, a small crowd gathered around the limo, expecting a star to emerge. I had hoped Jess would appease the autograph seekers with signatures like Jacques Cousteau or Jesus Christ. But instead, he bolted from the car and blew right through the crowd, just like a real star.
在摄影棚外，一小群人聚集在轿车周围，期待着明星出现。我曾希望杰斯能用像雅克·库斯托（Jacques Cousteau）或耶稣基督那样的签名来满足那些寻求签名的人。但他却猛地从车里冲出来，直接穿过人群，就像真正的明星一样。
Inside the building, we were shown around the stage before being led upstairs to the dressing room, where someone asked if we'd like a beer. "Sure," Jess said. "How does a bunch of imported beer sound?" The offer was supposed to impress us, and the sad truth is we were impressed. "Sounds good," Jess said.
在大楼内，我们被带去参观了舞台，然后被带到楼上的更衣室，有人问我们要不要啤酒。“当然，”杰斯说。“一堆进口啤酒听起来怎么样？”这个提议本应打动我们，可悲的事实是我们确实被打动了。“听起来不错，”杰斯说。
"And what do you guys want to eat? I'll go down to the deli and get whatever you want." This offer caught us off guard, since we had assumed a full spread of food would have been awaiting us. So we were unprepared to place an order. And when Jess gave his simple request, "A cheese sandwich," I nearly screamed, "Anything. We could have anything from the deli."
“你们想吃什么？我去熟食店给你们买任何你们想要的。”这个提议让我们措手不及，因为我们以为会有满满一桌食物等着我们。所以我们没准备好下订单。当杰斯提出他简单的要求，“一个奶酪三明治”时，我几乎尖叫道，“什么都可以。我们可以从熟食店买任何东西。”
"And a cheese sandwich for you, too?" she asked me. "Yeah," I said humbly, "but, you know, with a lot of things on it, vegetables and stuff." "Yeah, a lot of stuff on mine, too," Jess added.
“你也想要一个奶酪三明治吗？”她问我。“是的，”我谦虚地说，“但是，你知道，加很多东西，蔬菜什么的。”“是的，我的也要加很多东西，”杰斯补充道。
As soon as she left, we closed the door, and I felt relieved that we survived that first hurdle with relative ease. Then, stealthily, Jess handed me a scrap of paper which read, "Hidden cameras, microphones," and gave me a "you never know" look. We were soon passing notes and whispering.
她一走，我们就关上了门，我感到如释重负，我们相对轻松地挺过了第一道难关。然后，杰斯偷偷地递给我一张纸条，上面写着：“隐藏的摄像头，麦克风”，并给了我一个“谁知道呢”的眼神。我们很快就开始传纸条和耳语。
After only a few minutes of privacy, the talent coordinator entered. She walked right up to me and said, "Pete?" I shook my head and pointed her in Jess's direction. She shook Jess's hand, but then turned back to me. "Wait a minute. You're the guy in the photograph."
没过几分钟的隐私时间，才艺协调员进来了。她径直走到我面前说：“皮特？”我摇摇头，指了指杰斯的方向。她和杰斯握了手，但又转回来看我。“等一下。你是照片里那个人。”
Damn, they had dug up a picture of me. "He just poses for the photos sometimes," Jess said. His explanation didn't dampen her suspicion, since she kept staring at me. All I could say was, "He's Pete, not me. My name's Jerry." She was far from convinced.
该死，他们挖出了我的一张照片。“他只是有时为照片当模特，”杰斯说。他的解释并没有消除她的怀疑，因为她一直盯着我。我能说的只有，“他是皮特，不是我。我叫杰里（Jerry）。”她完全不相信。
"Really, guys. What's going on here?" Simultaneously, Jess and I began rambling varied and conflicting stories. Apparently, we hadn't settled on exactly which alibi we would use. The whole mission was on the brink of doom, but somehow, we were able to confuse her to the point where she seemed resigned that, at this late stage, so close to show time, it was in her interest to remain ignorant.
“真的，伙计们。这到底是怎么回事？”杰斯和我同时开始胡言乱语，说出各种不同且冲突的故事。显然，我们还没定好到底用哪个不在场证明。整个任务处于崩溃的边缘，但不知怎的，我们能把她搞糊涂到她似乎默认了，在这么晚的阶段，离节目播出这么近，保持无知对她有利。
The interrogation ceased, while she made small talk with Jess. After each question posed to Jess, she looked at me as if to gauge any reaction I may have had to Jess's responses. I did my best to disappear from her thoughts. I remained silent, stared out the window, and feigned boredom.
审讯停止了，而她和杰斯闲聊。在杰斯回答每个问题后，她都会看着我，好像在衡量我对杰斯回答的任何反应。我尽力从她的思维中消失。我保持沉默，盯着窗外，假装无聊。
When the talent coordinator finally took a seat, she didn't sit on a chair like me or on the couch, proper like Jess. Rather, she straddled the arm of the couch. With the arm being much higher than the seat of the couch and with her wearing a miniskirt, there was suddenly plenty of eye-level, exposed flesh inches away from Jess's face. It didn't appear to be accidental.
当才艺协调员最终坐下时，她没有像我一样坐在椅子上，也没有像杰斯一样坐在沙发上，端正地坐着。相反，她跨坐在沙发的扶手上。由于扶手比沙发座高得多，而且她穿着迷你裙，突然间杰斯的脸前几英寸处充满了齐眼高的暴露皮肤。这似乎不是偶然的。
When her chitchat with Jess turned flirtatious, I realized she was trying to use her sex appeal to get him to relax. This tactic backfired. Instead of being relaxed, Jess seemed uneasy with her presence and the attention she was giving him. He began to sweat.
当她和杰斯的闲聊变得调情时，我意识到她正在试图利用她的性感让杰斯放松。这一招适得其反。杰斯不仅没有放松，反而对她的存在以及她给他的关注感到不安。他开始出汗。
The flirting continued for another 10 minutes until she unexpectedly turned her focus on me, asking about my life, who I was, what I did, where I was from. My alias was simple. Jerry, a graphic designer from Soho. But the questions kept coming as if to trip me up, and I found myself struggling to explain who this Jerry character was. When she finally seemed satisfied with my answers and returned her attention to Jess, I quietly breathed a sigh of relief.
调情又持续了10分钟，直到她出人意料地把焦点转向我，问起我的生活，我是谁，我是干什么的，我从哪里来。我的化名很简单。杰里，苏豪区的一名图形设计师。但问题接二连三，好像是为了绊倒我，我发现自己正努力解释这个“杰里”角色是谁。当她最终似乎对我的回答感到满意并将注意力转回杰斯时，我悄悄地松了一口气。
Then the much-anticipated food arrived from the deli, and the talent coordinator left the room. We hoped to relax with our eats, but no sooner had she left then in walked the segment producer. The segment producer showed Jess six questions he had prepared for Letterman to ask and six prepared answers Letterman could expect to hear from Jess. To make sure Jess would know what to say on the air, the segment producer had Jess study the prepared answers and then conducted a pop quiz.
然后期待已久的食物从熟食店送到了，才艺协调员离开了房间。我们希望吃着东西放松一下，但她一走，节目制作人就进来了。节目制作人给杰斯看了他为莱特曼准备的六个问题，以及莱特曼可以期待从杰斯那里听到的六个准备好的回答。为了确保杰斯知道在广播中该说什么，节目制作人让杰斯研究了准备好的回答，然后进行了突击测验。
"OK, now say Letterman asks you question number three, how are you going to respond?" Suddenly, Jess was rehearsing lines. All the while, I quietly ate my sandwich, and drank my beer, and watched the show on the monitor.
“好吧，现在假设莱特曼问你第三个问题，你打算怎么回答？”突然，杰斯在背台词。我静静地吃着三明治，喝着啤酒，在监视器上看节目。
With show time rapidly approaching, we left the dressing room and headed downstairs towards the stage. In the tiny green room beside the stage, we sat watching the show on the monitor until the segment producer announced it was finally time. Jess rose, winked, and then disappeared. I made quick work in devouring the strawberries and grapes in a fruit bowl and was moving in on a plate of gourmet cookies when the television screen faded from black.
随着节目播出时间临近，我们离开更衣室，走向楼下的舞台。在舞台旁边的小绿色房间里，我们坐在那里在监视器上看节目，直到节目制作人宣布终于到了时候。杰斯站起来，眨了眨眼，然后消失了。我迅速吃完了果碗里的草莓和葡萄，正要对一盘美食饼干下手时，电视屏幕从黑色淡出。
Suddenly, there was Jess without the obligatory walk-across-the-stage entrance, already sitting next to Letterman. "Folks," Letterman said, "our next guest has spent the past 10 years working towards his ultimate goal, to wash dishes in every state in the Union. Here he is, a true American patriot, Dishwasher Pete." I dropped my cookie and laughed so hard, I slid off the couch.
突然，杰斯出现了，没有强制性的走过舞台的入口，已经坐在莱特曼旁边了。“各位，”莱特曼说，“我们的下一位嘉宾在过去10年里一直致力于他的终极目标，在联邦每一个州洗碗。他就是，一位真正的美国爱国者，洗碗工皮特。”我丢下饼干，笑得太厉害，从沙发上滑了下去。
One of the other two people in the green room asked, "Is that your friend?"
在绿色房间里的另外两个人中的一个问：“那是你的朋友吗？”
"Yeah," I cried between fits.
“是啊，”我在一阵狂笑中叫道。
"And that's really his goal? To wash dishes in all 50 states?"
“那真的是他的目标吗？在所有50个州洗碗？”
"Yeah."
“是啊。”
"That's very strange."
“那真是太奇怪了。”
"Yeah," I said again, but then realized this bozo was calling my friend Jess strange. No, wait, he was calling me strange. I was confused for a moment, but then the chuckling overwhelmed me again, and I no longer cared.
“是啊，”我再次说，但后来意识到这个笨蛋在说我的朋友杰斯很奇怪。不，等一下，他在说我奇怪。我有一瞬间感到困惑，但随后笑声再次淹没了我，我不再关心了。
Laughing almost nonstop, I caught almost none of the interview until I realized Letterman was steering Jess towards doing his Fire Hand trick. While Jess had lobbied the staff all along to let him do this trick, they had been so skeptical, I was sure they wouldn't allow him to do it.
不停地笑着，我几乎没听到采访的内容，直到我意识到莱特曼正在引导杰斯表演他的“火手”戏法。虽然杰斯一直游说工作人员让他表演这个戏法，他们一直持怀疑态度，但我确信他们不会让他做的。
Now, Pete, as I understand, to while away sometimes the lonely hours in the kitchen, you've taught yourself sort of a little kind of a trick. And from time to time on this show, we have something called Stupid Human Tricks. And I think this falls right smack in the middle of that category.
“那么，皮特，据我了解，为了打发厨房里孤独的时光，你自学了一种小戏法。而且在这个节目中，我们有时会有一个叫‘愚蠢的人类戏法’的环节。我想这正属于那个类别。”
Well, yeah, actually--
“嗯，是的，其实——”
Licking the plates. That's what it is.
“舔盘子。这就是它。”
You got to get free food, too. They don't pay enough. Yeah, one of the tricks that I learned was-- well, after an accident I had when I sliced my hand open-- I don't know if you can see a slight scar.
“你也得得到免费食物。他们付的钱不够多。是的，我学会的戏法之一是——嗯，在我出过一次事故把手切开后——我不知道你能不能看到那道轻微的疤痕。”
Well, I don't know that we want to see the slice, Pete, but we'll take your word for it.
“嗯，我不知道我们是否想看到伤口，皮特，但我们相信你的话。”
It's a five-and-a-half inch scar. It's from slicing my hand open. I had nerve surgery. And my hand is dead. But I can still move it.
“这是一道五英寸半的疤痕。是切开手造成的。我做了神经手术。我的手死了。但我还能移动它。”
So the story has a happy ending then.
“那么这个故事有个圆满的结局。”
But I can light cigarettes and cigars by catching my hand on fire and putting them up to the smoking--
“但我可以用手着火来点燃香烟和雪茄，然后把它们靠近——”
He can catch his hand on fire. May we dim the lights, please?
“他能让手着火。我们可以调暗灯光吗，请？”
The lights dimmed. Letterman put a cigar in his mouth and failed to notice Jess lighting not his scarred left hand, but his right hand. Jess thrust the flaming hand at Letterman's face who could only jump back in fright, his cigar unlit.
灯光调暗了。莱特曼把雪茄放进嘴里，没注意到杰斯点的不是他那只留疤的左手，而是右手。杰斯把那只着火的手猛地伸向莱特曼的脸，莱特曼只能惊恐地跳开，他的雪茄没点着。
I got scared. I saw a guy with a dead, flaming hand lunging at me. I don't know. It put me off. Good luck to you, Pete. Seems like you're a very nice young man.
“我被吓到了。我看到一个有着死掉、着火的手的家伙猛地冲向我。我不知道。这让我很不舒服。祝你好运，皮特。看来你是个非常好的年轻人。”
Thank you. Thank you.
“谢谢。谢谢。”
Dishwasher Pete. We'll be right back.
“洗碗工皮特。我们马上回来。”
And then before I knew it, the show was over, and I was alone in the green room. Immediately, I pounced on the refrigerator, but it held no beer. In fact, there was nothing edible in the whole room besides the gourmet cookies. I was searching for a container to stash the cookies in when Jess poked his head through the door just long enough to say, "Hey, let's get out of here." "But wait, Jess," I yelled, "cookies." But he was gone.
然后在我知道之前，节目就结束了，我独自留在绿色房间里。我立刻扑向冰箱，但里面没有啤酒。事实上，整个房间里除了美食饼干外没有可以吃的东西。我正找容器想把饼干藏起来时，杰斯探头进门，说了句足够长的话：“嘿，我们离开这儿吧。”“但等等，杰斯，”我大喊，“饼干。”但他已经走了。
I grabbed as many cookies as I could cradle in my arms and caught up to him at the elevator. Back upstairs, I rushed to the bathroom while Jess retrieved his stuff from the dressing room. We charged down the stairs, past Letterman's office, past his waiting minions, and finally, outside.
我抓起尽可能多抱在怀里的饼干，在电梯口追上了他。回到楼上，我冲进卫生间，而杰斯从更衣室取回了他的东西。我们冲下楼梯，经过莱特曼的办公室，经过他等待的随从，终于，到了外面。
Jess led the charge past the crowd, knocking aside at least one autograph book held out for him to sign. People were shouting my name. Excited, I assumed there was some friends in the crowd. But then I saw a pack of frat boys emerge from the mass and rush towards Jess. "Pete, Pete," they yelled. Terrified, Jess dove in the limousine and slammed the door.
杰斯领头穿过人群，打掉至少一本递过来让他签名的签名簿。人们在叫我的名字。我很兴奋，以为人群中有一些朋友。但随后我看到一群兄弟会成员从人群中冒出来，冲向杰斯。“皮特，皮特，”他们喊道。杰斯吓坏了，钻进豪华轿车，砰地关上了门。
The following day, Letterman's staff found out that they'd been duped when several curious friends called the show to find out what had happened. For a couple of weeks, we weren't sure if we were going to see the $500 they owed us for the appearance. But as it turned out, The Letterman Show was eager to bury the whole incident with as little fuss or publicity as possible. So we were paid without having to raise a ruckus. Now The Letterman Show officially has no comment about Dishwasher Pete.
第二天，莱特曼的员工发现他们被骗了，因为几个好奇的朋友打电话到节目组询问发生了什么事。有几个星期，我们不确定是否能拿到他们欠我们出场费的500美元。但事实证明，莱特曼节目急于掩盖整个事件，尽量不引起骚乱或宣传。所以我们拿到了钱，而不需要大惊小怪。现在，莱特曼节目正式对洗碗工皮特没有任何评论。
Dishwasher Pete's story about The Letterman Show appears in the zine Dishwasher. If you want to get a copy, you can write to this address. Grab a pen. Dishwasher, PO Box 8213, Portland, Oregon, 97207.
洗碗工皮特关于莱特曼节目的故事出现在杂志《洗碗工》中。如果你想买一本，你可以写信到这个地址。拿支笔。Dishwasher, PO Box 8213, Portland, Oregon, 97207。
What do you sacrifice when you change your name? What do you give up when you take on another, more reckless identity? We carry this question with us into the next act. Act Four, Nom De Plume, Nom De Guerre.
当你改名时你牺牲了什么？当你采取另一个、更鲁莽的身份时，你放弃了什么？我们将这个问题带入下一幕。第四幕，化名，战争名字。
One of the most original music writers in this country does not write for the mainstream magazines like Spin or Rolling Stone. In fact, he doesn't write for magazines at all. His "name"-- and I'm putting name in quotes here because it's not his real name-- is Camden Joy. He prints his opinions on posters which he plasters all over New York and publishes in little pamphlets with titles like "The Lost Manifestos of Camden Joy."
这个国家最原创的音乐作家之一不为Spin或Rolling Stone等主流杂志写稿。事实上，他根本不为杂志写稿。他的“名字”——我在这里把名字加引号是因为那不是他的真名——是卡姆登·乔伊（Camden Joy）。他把自己的观点印在海报上，贴满纽约，并在小册子上发表，标题如《卡姆登·乔伊遗失的宣言》。
Regular listeners may remember hearing him on our Frank Sinatra show. He wrote a story for us about watching the movie The Manchurian Candidate on a TV in a kabob restaurant with a bunch of cabbies. Sarah Vowell, one of our contributing editors, is a music critic herself and went to New York to find out more about Camden Joy, the man, the myth.
经常收听的听众可能记得在我们法兰克·辛纳屈（Frank Sinatra）节目中听到过他。他为我们写了一个关于在烤肉餐厅的电视上和一群出租车司机看电影《满洲候选人》（The Manchurian Candidate）的故事。莎拉·沃威尔（Sarah Vowell），我们的特约编辑之一，她自己也是一位音乐评论家，她去了纽约，想要找出关于卡姆登·乔伊、这个人、这个神话的更多信息。
I'm a sucker for a condensed, exaggerated emotion. Its what made me fall for rock and roll in the first place. And Camden Joy's manifestos work like good pop songs. Each one short, crisp, and strange. Reading his bizarre claim that Paul Simon's Graceland was the best album of the 1980s, that a Mekon's cassette saved his life, that he, Camden Joy, should father Madonna's baby, that an obscure, little group called Yo La Tengo are "great, like Chinese food," I felt like there was no one in the world who cared more about what guitars and drums can do.
我容易被浓缩、夸张的情感所吸引。这就是最初让我爱上摇滚乐的原因。而卡姆登·乔伊的宣言就像好的流行歌曲一样运作。每一篇都很短、干脆、奇怪。读到他那古怪的主张，比如保罗·西蒙（Paul Simon）的《Graceland》是1980年代最好的专辑，一张Mekon的磁带救了他的命，他，卡姆登·乔伊，应该做麦当娜孩子的父亲，一个鲜为人知的小团体Yo La Tengo是“伟大的，就像中国菜”，我感觉世界上再没有比他更关心吉他和鼓能做什么的人了。
One of my favorites dealt with the global economic impact of the Indie band, Pavement. It goes like this. "I hereby suggest that the American president and all them trade reps haul Pavement to the trade talks. They are our grandest export, our finest product, infusable in hot weather, our best materials. Pavement should be carried on our shoulders, and emblazoned on our backs, and ushered onto waiting planes at the last minute with an almost effete, deliberate importance, their bellies bloated with our very best meats."
我最喜欢的一篇是关于独立乐队Pavement对全球经济的影响。它是这样写的。“我谨建议美国总统和所有贸易代表把Pavement带到贸易谈判中。他们是我们最宏大的出口产品，我们最好的产品，在炎热天气里可注入，我们最好的材料。Pavement应该被扛在我们的肩膀上，印在我们的背上，并在最后一分钟被迎上等待的飞机，带着一种近乎颓废的、刻意的重视，他们的肚子鼓胀着我们最好的肉。”
Charles Aaron, an editor at Spin, remembers stumbling upon the Pavement piece as an orange handbill on a telephone pole by his Brooklyn subway stop. It was the first time he saw one of Joy's posters. The headline just said, "Pavement."
查尔斯·亚伦（Charles Aaron），Spin的一位编辑，记得他在布鲁克林地铁站的电线杆上偶然发现了那张橘色的传单，上面写着关于Pavement的文章。那是他第一次看到乔伊的海报。标题只写了“Pavement”。
And I couldn't imagine that it was really about the band, Pavement. I thought it was maybe about a paving company or something. But then I read it, and it was this impassioned review of, I think, their Crooked Rain album, and also about how magnetic and awe-inspiring Steve Malkmus, the singer, was. And it wasn't that well written a review, but it was so impassioned. And as it went to the end, it became more like a stalker letter.
我无法想象那真的是关于乐队Pavement。我以为可能是关于一家铺路公司之类的。但后来我读了它，那是对的，我想是他们的《Crooked Rain》专辑的热情评论，也关于主唱史蒂夫·马尔克穆斯（Steve Malkmus）是多么有吸引力和令人敬畏。那并不是写得很好的评论，但它太热情了。当它写到最后时，它变得更像是一封跟踪者的信。
And I knew that at one point Steve Malkmus had lived in the neighborhood, and I started to get worried that this was someone who was stalking him. And so I almost wanted to take it down. It was disturbing. It was funny though. It was possibly a joke. It seemed less like a joke. It seemed more disturbing than a joke.
我知道史蒂夫·马尔克穆斯曾经住在附近，我开始担心这是一个在跟踪他的人。所以我几乎想把它撕下来。这令人不安。不过很有趣。这可能是一个笑话。它看起来不那么像个笑话。它看起来比笑话更令人不安。
Probably a couple weeks later, I was coming back home from the laundromat. And this time, I was staring down at the ground, and there was another one, long, impassioned review veering into stalker-like comments about Yo La Tengo. These were not the most well-known bands in the world. And I just couldn't understand where these handbills could possibly be coming from. I felt like I was one of, maybe, 5 to 10 people in this zip code who would actually know who these bands were. It got to the point where I felt like someone was planting them for me to find.
大概几周后，我从洗衣店回来。这次，我盯着地面看，那里有另一张，长篇、热情、转向类似跟踪者评论的关于Yo La Tengo的评论。这些不是世界上最知名的乐队。我简直无法理解这些传单是从哪里来的。我觉得我可能是这个邮区里实际上知道这些乐队是谁的5到10个人之一。达到了一种我觉得有人在种下它们等我去发现的地步。
And do you know his real name?
你知道他的真名吗？
No, I don't. And people have refused to tell me. I guess because I seem interested. If I was disinterested, they would probably tell me right out. But they see that I'm semi-fascinated, so they want to keep the myth going.
不，我不知道。而且人们拒绝告诉我。我想因为我看起来很感兴趣。如果我表现得很冷淡，他们可能会直接告诉我。但他们看出我半着迷了，所以他们想保持那个神话。
So Camden Joy or whoever you are, can you tell me how long you've been Camden Joy?
那么卡姆登·乔伊，或者不管你是谁，你能告诉我你当卡姆登·乔伊多久了吗？
I've been Camden Joy for about four years.
我当卡姆登·乔伊大约四年了。
What's your real first name?
你真正的名字是什么？
My real first name is Tom.
我真正的名字是汤姆（Tom）。
Tom. How do I know you're telling me the truth?
汤姆。我怎么知道你在说真话？
You don't. Oh, did you want the truth?
你不知道。哦，你想听真话？
He says he decided on the name Camden when he was visiting Trenton, New Jersey. He says he went there looking for the darkest, most depressing American city. But the locals had this advice.
他说他在访问新泽西州特伦顿（Trenton）时决定了“卡姆登”这个名字。他说他去那里是为了寻找最黑暗、最令人沮丧的美国城市。但当地人有这样的建议。
"You really should go down to Camden."
“你真的应该去卡姆登（Camden）。”
Camden, New Jersey?
新泽西州的卡姆登？
Camden, New Jersey. And I said, "Why?" And they said, "Well, it's a lot like Trenton, but without all the thrills."
新泽西州的卡姆登。我说，“为什么？”他们说，“嗯，它很像特伦顿，但没有那么多刺激。”
He claims that calling himself Camden opened a window, that it gave him permission to experiment with his writing, to say whatever he wanted, to be whoever he wanted.
他声称称自己为卡姆登打开了一扇窗，这给了他实验写作的许可，随心所欲地说任何他想说的话，成为他想成为的任何人。
Doesn't Tom have a real job?
汤姆没有真正的工作吗？
Yes.
有的。
What does Tom do?
汤姆是做什么的？
Well, right now, Tom works as a word processor.
嗯，现在，汤姆做文字处理工作。
I feel like I'm talking to Sybil or something. So at Tom's job, where does he process words? Tom?
我觉得我在和希比尔（Sybil）说话或者别的什么。所以汤姆的工作，他在哪里处理文字？汤姆？
At a world-famous law firm in New York City.
在纽约市一家世界著名的律师事务所。
And do the world-famous lawyers, do they address Tom as "Tom"?
那些世界著名的律师，他们称呼汤姆为“汤姆”吗？
Yes, they do.
是的，他们是这样。
And do they know about Camden? Do they know Tom's dirty, little secret?
他们知道卡姆登吗？他们知道汤姆肮脏的小秘密吗？
They could care less. If I went in there and I said, "Yeah, I'll type your lousy deposition, but can I tell you while I'm doing this what a world-important artist I am?" That wouldn't really be conducive to a good work environment.
他们才不在乎。如果我走进去说，“是的，我会打你们那该死的证词记录，但在我做这个的时候，我能告诉你们我是多么重要的艺术家吗？”那对良好的工作环境没什么帮助。
Does Tom dress differently? Does Tom wear different clothes than Camden? I know Camden obviously must wear a cape.
汤姆穿衣服有什么不同吗？汤姆穿的衣服和卡姆登不同吗？我知道卡姆登显然必须穿斗篷。
No, they share a lot. They share toothbrushes and clothes. They sleep on the same pillows.
不，他们共享很多东西。他们共用牙刷和衣服。他们睡在同一个枕头上。
Now say you're at a party. And you're introducing yourself to someone. Who do you say? Do you say, "Hi, I'm Camden Joy," or do you say, "Hi, I'm Tom Doe," or whatever?
现在假设你在一个聚会上。你正向某人介绍自己。你怎么说？你说，“嗨，我是卡姆登·乔伊”，还是说，“嗨，我是汤姆·多伊（Tom Doe）”，或者别的？
I, ah-- I-- I ah-- hmmm.
我，啊——我——我啊——嗯。
Joy is such a trickster and so accustomed to playing around with personae and hyperbole that by the end of the time I spent with him, I no longer trusted a word he said. His poster campaign while I was there sort of frightened me. It's one thing for a man to verbally stalk the lead singer of Pavement. It's something else to stalk his ex-girlfriend.
乔伊是个骗子，习惯于用人格和夸张手法玩弄，以至于我花在他身上的时间结束时，我不相信他说的一个字。我还在那儿的时候，他的海报活动让我感到有点害怕。一个人口头跟踪Pavement的主唱是一回事。跟踪他的前女友是另一回事。
It was Valentine's Day. And the posters ranted against the phone company, claiming that his girlfriend broke up with him because he couldn't call her. He says he couldn't find a pay phone that worked. And when he did, he was out of change. We had a little debate in front of this poster in Soho.
那是情人节。海报反对电话公司，声称他的女朋友和他分手了，因为他无法给她打电话。他说他找不到一个能用的公用电话。当他找到时，他又没有零钱。我们在苏豪区的一张海报前进行了小小的辩论。
So it's your theory that you tape up all over town these paranoid rants against the phone company. And that's what brings the women to your door.
所以你的理论是你贴遍全城那些反对电话公司的偏执狂 rant。这就是把你女朋友带到你门口的原因。
It's never proven false yet. You go into bars. I see guys doing this all the time. They go into bars, and they explain that their hands are freezing cold and they're suffering from frostbite because they've been up all night postering to their last girlfriend. And time and again, these are the guys that leave the bar accompanied not just by one, but by many, many women.
还没被证明是假的。你去酒吧。我一直看到人们这样做。他们去酒吧，解释说他们的手冰凉，他们患了冻伤，因为他们整晚都在贴海报给他们的最后一个女朋友。一次又一次，这些离开酒吧的人不仅有一个，而是被许多、许多女性陪伴。
So this woman is going to read the phrase, what, "I was trying to use the pay phone, but my hands, slick from pizza grease, only shined the receiver and could not lift it from the cradle." You think women want boys whose hands are slick from pizza grease, that that's the boys they want?
所以这位女士会读到那句话，什么，“我正试图使用公用电话，但我的手，滑得沾满了披萨油，只是擦亮了听筒，无法把它从底座上拿起。”你认为女人想要那些手沾满披萨油的男孩吗，那是她们想要的男孩吗？
This last girlfriend of mine, pizza grease was a catch-all thing that we would-- I don't want to get too specific, but I would say that pizza grease, it's a lubricant, I think I could say. And it's certainly a lubricant of the heart in this case.
我最后一个女朋友，披萨油是我们会——我不想说得太具体，但我想说披萨油，它是一种润滑剂，我想我能说。在这种情况下，它肯定是心脏的润滑剂。
A lubricant of the heart?
心脏的润滑剂？
Yeah, what I'm saying here is that I'm a man. I'm a man, and I have an appetite.
是的，我想说的是我是一个男人。我是一个男人，我有食欲。
Later, when I tell Joy that his stalker impulses towards his ex-girlfriend make me nervous, he tells me that the whole thing, even the weirdest poster called Camden's Conspiracy Hearts, was just a big put-on art project and that he and the woman parted amiably. Then when I ask if I could corroborate this with her, he says that there was no single woman, just a composite of several women. Here I was, drawn to Joy's writing because I thought it was so emotionally raw, so embarrassingly honest, when really, it's a web of fictions. This was interesting and exasperating. But it gets even more complicated.
后来，当我告诉乔伊，他对前女友的跟踪冲动让我感到紧张时，他告诉我，整个事情，甚至那张名为《卡姆登的阴谋心》的最怪异的海报，都只是一个巨大的艺术项目，他和那个女人友好地分开了。当我问我是否能跟她核实这件事时，他说没有那个女人，只是几个女人的综合体。我就在这里，被乔伊的写作吸引，因为我认为它情感非常原始，尴尬地诚实，而实际上，它是一个虚构的网络。这很有趣，也很令人恼火。但它变得更加复杂了。
There's another name that I'm writing under right now, too.
现在还有另一个名字，我也在用它写作。
Now wait a minute. What does this person write? Is he a journalist, the other guy? The third man? The third man.
等一下。那个人写什么？他是记者吗，那个人？第三个人。第三个人。
There was a third man. He roams freely amongst the different things.
有第三个人。他在不同的东西之间自由漫游。
What does that mean? Tell me what he writes.
那是什么意思？告诉我他写什么。
He writes poetry and some rather poetic music reviews, I suppose.
他写诗和一些相当有诗意的音乐评论，我想。
Oh, poetic music reviews.
哦，有诗意的音乐评论。
Poetic music reviews. I know that sounds awful.
有诗意的音乐评论。我知道那听起来很糟糕。
What rhymes with Elvis? No, just kidding.
什么和猫王（Elvis）押韵？不，开玩笑的。
Purple.
紫色（Purple）。
Well, the other day you told me you were at a Pavement show, and you were picking up on some girl. What name did you give her?
嗯，前几天你告诉我你在看Pavement的演出，你在搭讪一个女孩。你告诉她什么名字？
Camden.
卡姆登。
Camden. And she took your word for it?
卡姆登。她相信你了？
Yeah. We should point out that I wasn't successful in any way. And it could be that Tom could have been far more successful.
是的。我们应该指出我并没有以任何方式成功。汤姆可能要成功得多。
Maybe Tom should have gone back and tried again.
也许汤姆应该回去再试一次。
It wasn't just that I didn't successfully pick up on this woman, but that--
不仅是我没能成功搭讪那个女人，而且——
Tom strikes out, the third guy comes.
汤姆出局了，第三个人来了。
One telling way to sum up the difference between Camden and Tom is examining their attitudes about Freedy Johnston. Camden devoted his cruelest manifesto to the folk rocker, spewing, "I would crawl through glass to claw your eyes. I would offer a hug if my suit were explosive."
总结卡姆登和汤姆之间区别的一个明显方式是审视他们对弗雷迪·约翰斯顿（Freedy Johnston）的态度。卡姆登把他最残酷的宣言献给了这位民谣摇滚歌手，喷道：“我会爬过玻璃去抓你的眼睛。如果我的西装是爆炸性的，我会给你一个拥抱。”
I think Tom would hear Freedy Johnston playing on the muzak of a store like Bed Bath & Beyond, and this sort of occurrence would just make his shoulders droop a bit. And he'd go, "Darn it, he used to be so good. Darn it, I wonder what happened to him." Tom is a person who has felt often absent of opinions and often a little bit excluded by things. And Camden is desperately trying to make up for that by coming up with rather fanciful and wild opinions often woven out of complete insanity.
我想汤姆会听到弗雷迪·约翰斯顿在像Bed Bath & Beyond这样的商店的背景音乐中播放，这种发生的事情会让他的肩膀有点下垂。他会说，“该死，他曾经那么好。该死，不知道他发生了什么事。”汤姆是一个经常感到没有意见，经常被事情排除在外一点点的人。而卡姆登则通过提出常常编织着完全疯狂的、相当奇思妙想和狂野的意见，拼命试图弥补这一点。
Good writing, which is to say, real communication, lies somewhere between Tom's lack of opinions and Camden's surplus of them. When you take on a new name, when you split yourself into two people like that, you think the new name's going to make things easier. But what actually happens is that your life becomes twice as complex. It's almost as if the two alter egos need an introduction, as if they need someone to walk up and say, "Camden, I'd like you to meet Tom. Tom, this is Camden Joy."
好的写作，也就是真正的沟通，存在于汤姆缺乏意见和卡姆登过剩意见之间。当你采取一个新名字，当你像那样把自己分裂成两个人时，你会认为新名字会让事情变得更容易。但实际上发生的是，你的生活变得复杂了两倍。几乎就好像这两个替代人格需要一个介绍，几乎就好像他们需要有人走上去说，“卡姆登，我想让你见见汤姆。汤姆，这是卡姆登·乔伊。”
Well, our program was produced today by Nancy Updike and myself with Peter Clowney and Alix Spiegel. Contributing editors Sarah Vowell, Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, and Margy Rochlin. Production help today from Kristina Stevens and from WDUQ Pittsburgh. If you'd like a copy of this program, it only costs $10. Call us at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380, 312-832-3380. Our email address, [email protected] .
好了，我们的节目今天由南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）和我本人制作，还有彼得·克劳尼（Peter Clowney）和阿利克斯·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel）。特约编辑莎拉·沃威尔、保罗·塔夫（Paul Tough）、杰克·希特和玛吉·罗克林。今天的制作帮助来自克里斯蒂娜·史蒂文斯（Kristina Stevens）和匹兹堡WDUQ电台。如果你想要这个节目的副本，只需10美元。请致电芝加哥WBEZ，312-832-3380，312-832-3380。我们的电子邮件地址，[email protected]。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who reminds you--
WBEZ管理监督托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia），他提醒你——
Imperial Sesame Street Polish Kielbasa, it better than cookie.
芝麻街御用波兰基尔巴萨香肠，它比饼干更好。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
But wait, Jess, cookies.
但等等，杰斯，饼干。